whether you're a fan of the card game
itself or you're in it for the story of
restoring an ancient Pharaoh's long-lost
memories there are plenty of little
details from yugioh that casual fans
could have easily missed like many
popular anime yu-gi-oh started life as a
manga see realized in the popular manga
magazine weekly shonen jump in this
original manga creator kazuki takahashi
had a somewhat different vision for the
series than what happens on screen
protagonist Yugi Muto whose name was
changed to Yugi moto in the English dub
is a bullied high school student his
grandfather who owns a game shop allows
him to attempt to put together an
ancient relic known as the Millennium
Puzzle which yugi of course
solves this should all sound familiar to
fans so far where the manga series takes
a turn is that the alter-ego that
possesses Yugi after the puzzles
completion isn't an unwaveringly just
game master instead this dark entity
doles out vigilante justice against
bullies and criminals going so far as to
permanently disfigure brainwash or
dispatch them these early chapters of
the manga don't focus just on the card
game magic and wizards as it was
originally known but instead rotate
between various diverse games of chance
and skill when an opponent challenges
this dark Yugi it's a bit like
challenging death to a game of chess
with impossible stakes and unsavory
outcomes
sorry death
you lose professor plum this early
yu-gi-oh is much more of a horror series
than what it would become later in its
serialization the anime series that is
most popular in the Western world is not
the only yugioh anime before na s and
Studio gallop had their go at making one
of the most popular Shonen anime of the
2000s Toei animation produced what has
come to be known by some fans as season
zero this late 90s attempt has never had
an official english-language release
unfortunately but even Western fans are
aware of how it differs from what the
majority of us know as Yukio season zero
hues more closely to the mangas original
story
luring those dark themes of vigilante
justice meted out by a cruel and savvy
Gamesmaster
it also sticks more closely to
Takahashi's original art style which in
the early days was distinguished by his
characters cuter more rounded features
since licensers have gone this long
without attempting to bring this anime
stateside we don't think it's likely to
ever find its way into the North
American market still it's a nifty piece
of history of the series and it's many
iterations in the early manga and the
original 1998 anime adaptation there is
a brief story about a character with a
penchant for American superheroes Hana
Saki a classmate of Yugi's is obsessed
with the American superhero comic zombie
a zombie er definitely seems to be a bit
of a spoof on the characters spawn and
it is clear from Takahashi's story that
he has a good understanding of what the
American comics landscape of the mid-90s
was like in fact he and comics creator
Mike Minneola even did an art trade
swapping yugioh and Hellboy mashup
pieces
more recently Takahashi has provided the
artwork for Japanese only Marvel Comics
involving spider-man and Iron Man it's
clear that Takahashi is a fan of Western
comics and influenced by them as much as
he is by other manga when something is
translated for a different audience
things end up changing however hardcore
yu-gi-oh fans are often disgruntled
about some of the changes that occurred
between the Japanese version of the
series and the English adaptation by
4kids entertainment the former was
intended for a young teenage audience
while for kids naturally tried to market
it to younger kids to start out the
majority of the characters had their
names changed from their original
Japanese to more English friendly names
Jono Chi was changed to Joey Honda to
Tristan on Zoo Tootie and so on this is
a common enough practice when anime is
intended for younger audiences but
surely there are Japanese kids in
America who would love to hear names
like theirs on their favorite television
programs beyond this the English
adaptation refers to the Millennium
Puzzle as five thousand years old
whereas the original Japanese has it at
a more
since three thousand years old the
opening and closing songs in Japanese
are well written pop songs but American
kids were rocking out to a high-powered
largely wordless tune
perhaps the most shocking change of all
is the addition in English of something
called The Shadow Realm
when yami-yugi duels opponents and wins
he occasionally sends their minds to a
place referred by this ominous name in
the original however villains just died
there was no sugarcoating the outcomes
of these duels and Japanese my
Millennium Puzzle protects me from your
cowardly assault but nothing will
protect you it's easy to get distracted
by all the card playing going on in
yugioh but the truth is that there is a
ton of fascinating lore hiding in the
background viewers know that the
Millennium Puzzle is an ancient artifact
with dark powers and at the beginning of
the series it seems as though it brings
out a cool commanding alter ego of Yugi
as the series progresses however it
becomes clear that this alter-ego is his
own person albeit one who cannot
remember who he is though most of the
other Millennium items contain great
dark power there is only one other the
Millennium ring which also houses a
separate entity the ring is worn by Joel
Bakura a likable and timid young man
with a penchant for the McCobb when
under the influence of the ring he
becomes an entity known as yami-bakura
an evil character who tries to Fort
Yugi's efforts at every turn as Yugi and
Bakura deal with their own dark
personalities it becomes more and more
obvious that they are harboring two
individuals who have a long history
together in the final season
yami-bakura challenges Yami Yugi to a
game set in ancient Egypt where the
story of their conflict is played out
the stakes involved Yami Yugi lost
memory and the fate of the world itself
are you saying that everything we do
the events of the match are you when the
majority of people think of yugioh they
remember the series that is centered
solely on Yugi and his friends but even
though the initial viewers grew up and
moved on to other franchises the success
of the series and its real-world trading
card game inspired a slew of spin-offs
each new iteration keeps the central
theme of dueling with cards but adds its
own spin or unique monster types to keep
the action fresh in the audience
involved the first of these spin-offs
yu-gi-oh GX follows Judah Yuki called
Jaden Yuki and English as he makes his
way through the prestigious Duel Academy
as a connection to the first series the
school is founded by the original series
antagonist the hyper rich super genius
Seto Kaiba
since viewers seem to enjoy that for
more series followed in quick succession
yu-gi-oh 5ds yu-gi-oh zexal ukyo arc V
and yu-gi-oh brains with each new
installation comes a further focus on
the intersection of dueling and tech a
theme which has been part of the series
ever since Seto Kaiba stepped onto the
scene with his duel disks there is also
a new as of yet unnamed spinoff series
set to premiere in 2020 four years after
rains hit TV and it's anybody's guess as
to how the gameplay will evolve from its
most recent digital world makeover as we
now know Yugi oh hasn't always been
about the card game despite what the
merchandising team wants you to think
even though the most popular anime
series focuses significantly on the
cards and their lore and creation
tabletop role-playing games also play a
significant role in the plot itself in
the manga the shine new kid on the block
Bakura invites Yugi and his friends over
to play a game of Monster World a sort
of in series version of Dungeons &
Dragons during this game the spirit of
the Millennium ring takes hold of Bakura
changing the stakes so that any false
move sees one of the players sealed
inside their individual game piece
unless you can break them out this
storyline was pretty violent which was
probably why it was adapted for the
season zero anime but never made it into
the later adaptations plus as we
mentioned earlier the final
season of the original series saw
yami-bakura as game master once again
taking yami-yugi on a trip down ancient
memory lane in a tabletop campaign
called memory world most people
especially kids don't really think twice
about how their anime gets to them the
fact is there's a lot of time
negotiation and work that goes into
acquiring the rights to air in anime in
another country plus all the work that
goes into voice acting and making the
series presentable to a new audience and
sometimes there are issues that arise as
a result of licensing in 2011 American
licensing company for Kids Entertainment
was sued by Tokyo TV and nihon ad
systems for breach of contract the
conflict arose around for kids
withholding funds from the licensers
that they earned through deals with
companies like Funimation and Cartoon
Network for kids ended up filing for
chapter 11 bankruptcy following the suit
and then claimed to have bounced back
from it in 2012 however they filed again
in 2016 fortunately for kids legal
troubles hasn't stopped yugioh from
being available to stream the series is
available through streaming on
Funimation's website as well as through
crunchyroll Netflix and Hulu
unsurprisingly dueling in the real world
doesn't quite match up with dueling as
it's represented in the anime for one
thing while we call them yu-gi-oh cards
the characters in show refer to their
decks as duel monsters cards and in both
the manga and all of the anime
iterations of the series the rules of
duel monsters are pretty fast and loose
in order to make a playable game more
structured rules have been set for those
of us playing along at home another key
difference is the cards themselves
however everyone recognizes the Dark
Magician or blue-eyes White Dragon cards
but there are a handful of cards from
the series that either never made it
into the physical realm or are no longer
usable when playing by competition rules
despite its frequent use and explanation
in the series the spell card pot of
greed is no longer acceptable in a
real-life match vicunas favorite card
change of heart is also a no-go
unfortunately if you want to use these
in a real match
well and this time you don't stand a
ghost of a chance using all of your
allowance on yu-gi-oh cards as a kid was
a common enough experience but as we age
it becomes less viable to spend money
that way never mind finding the time and
friends with which to duel luckily there
are other means of engaging with the
series that can be enjoyed at any age
and within any budget like all
successful anime series yugioh has
spawned several video games many of
these games haven't made it out of Japan
but there are a few which have the first
was yugioh dark duel stories for the
Game Boy Color which pitted the player
against characters from the series in
order to progress and acquire new cards
pretty straightforward yu-gi-oh duelists
of the Roses however takes a different
tack in this game players chose the side
of the House of Lancaster or the House
of York and duel in a plot that is
loosely based on the real-world War of
the Roses
the gameplay unfolds on a playing map
that has different terrain helping or
hindering certain monsters in those
areas this game expands upon what fans
know from the series to create a new
challenge of course games and game
systems cost money but most people have
a phone or tablet these days with those
devices you can download the official
Konami app yugioh duel links which
allows players to duel characters or
real players from across the world in
real time keeping the spirit of
one-on-one matches alive in other words
it's always
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite anime are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you